u.s. immigration officials are defending
their actions after civil rights
activists accused them of setting
deportation traps for undocumented
immigrants who are legally trying to
change their status a new lawsuit filed
by the ACLU claims at least 17 people
have been arrested by ice agents at
citizenship offices around New England
so far this year all 17 are seeking
legal status through family connections
to u.s. citizens such as marriage as
Jeff Pegues reports the ACLU are used
this should protect their path to
citizenship I was crying I felt like my
body went into shock million Calderon an
undocumented immigrant and Luis Gordy a
US citizen were shaken when an interview
to confirm their marriage back in
January turned into a bust by ice
officers what was flashing through your
mind oh my god I'm never gonna see my
kids I'm not gonna see my husband
the ACLU challenged Calder owns
detention and secured her release after
nearly a month now they are suing the
government on behalf of five couples who
all had almost identical experiences you
think they were trapped
we know they were trapped from the
documents that the government itself has
provided those documents include emails
that apparently reveal coordination
between US Citizenship and Immigration
Services and Immigration and Customs
Enforcement or ice and their alleged
attempts to hide it in one email and ice
official asks a CIS employee to delay a
citizenship interview by 15 minutes so
two immigration officers could get there
to make an arrest in another email and
ice employee proposes that CIS spread
their immigration interviews apart to
avoid negative media interests from
multiple arrests around the same times
so do you feel like you were set up yeah
you do oh yeah Fabiano and cara de
oliveira are not part of the ACLU
lawsuit but faced a similar situation at
a different USCIS office they're like
well we're gonna approve your your
marriage because it's real we're gonna
give you the paperwork so you must have
been thrilled when yeah it was great and
then he told Fabiano ice was in the back
and they wanted to speak with him
in a statement ice
called allegations of inappropriate
coordination between them and the USCIS
unfounded insisting that what they're
doing is lawful and legitimate but the
ACLU disagrees saying federal
regulations protect their clients path
to citizenship this is not about the
government pursuing a law-and-order
agenda it's about the government
stopping people who are trying to follow
the law
the ACLU believes that this should be a
class-action lawsuit to protect those
trying to get a green card from getting
arrested there will be a court hearing
in the case in the federal courthouse
behind me on Monday for CBS this morning
Jeff Pegues in Boston thank you Jeff